all right 5 30 in a monday morning john
project reel helping young people figure
out how the real world works with a
guidebook called
government
independence
and you that's big title heather it is a
big title with a big job right because
it's all about navigating real life
young adults facing of course economic
challenges following the pandemic and
heck being just a young adult is a
challenge you've been an older one too
an adult right mary jane belly isn't
joining us live at the west charleston
library with some details on this book
mary jane good morning
heather good morning to you well it took
more than five years for that guidebook
government independence and you to come
to life and project real has given away
nearly three thousand copies for free
the guide explains all the laws that are
very likely to impact the lives of young
adults just graduating high school and
attending college the nonprofit has
spent a few years compiling information
and surveying young adults and what
issues they face the most it helps
prepare young adults to give them an
economic and professional leg up a
number of topics are covered including
job interviews credit development
healthy adult relationships and much
more
we can't provide legal advice and that's
something we have to be cautious of but
we can do is provide practical
information
within the context of laws that shape
the way we interact with adult life in a
world like right now where so much
information is at our fingertips like
online and that we can look online for
these things
i just think that the textbook is a
wonderful resource that it is reliable
and it has been fact checked
now while you can get a copy of
government independence and you online
project real is encouraging you to also
pick up a printed copy and i did give a
copy to my sister she's starting her
second year of college and as a
sophomore you know she says that i could
really use this and i was wondering
where my copy was when i was growing up
i could have also used something like
this so you can pick up a copy at any
clark county library including this one
at the west charleston campus off of
torrey pines and charleston reporting
live mary jane balleza live local now
mary jane i could probably still use a
copy thank you for that